there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the King died that was
last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
Barry Allen first way you said that like
it explains why there's a total stranger
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair he said he'll fight with
us
more or less probably more or less he
said no he said no look man I don't know
who you are but whoever you're looking
for
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities see
I believe enemies are coming and stop
right there
I'm in you are just like that yeah I
need friends
alright guys heat this
I heard about you didn't think you were
real
I realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
hey youtubers is Charlie they totally
brought Justice League footage I was so
surprised it gives you a really good
idea for the humor of the film so let's
break it down this is so great so you
can see the aesthetic is a lot different
from the Wonder Woman movie you know
each of the characters has their own
identity so when they get their solo
films like the flash movie for instance
it'll be much more in the tone of Barry
Allen that you see in this and in the
tone you see these Justice League film
so like you have this really grimy look
like the world is in this really dark
place like he's up in this fishing
village trying to get Aquaman in the
beginning of the trailer but then as
they move through the rest of the clip
things brighten up a little bit like the
tone picks up the music kicks in is like
a really fun take on the classic idea of
putting the band together which is the
whole reason for sidelining
Superman like at the end of Batman V
Superman they give you this teaser like
you know that he's gonna be in Justice
League but they really wanted Batman to
have the job of putting the team
together so that it wasn't just like a
God showing up saying follow me I'm this
amazing God so like he has that funny
comment with Wonder Woman where she's
like is you know more or less is he on
the team is he gonna be fighting us
what's what's going on and Batman's like
yeah he's probably gonna be fighting us
quite a bit then Aquaman body slams him
against the wall so you get an idea for
the tone of each of the characters but I
kind of mentioned it in my Wonder Woman
video James Wan was on stage at
comic-con and he's a great horror film
director and he's bringing a lot of that
energy to Aquaman like the actual
environment that Aquaman lives in is
very terrified like when you go down
that deep there big sea monsters so I
think that Aquaman it's gonna be like
DC's version of a really awesome horror
film but it'll also be contrasted with
the majesty like the glory of Atlantis
but we finally get an actual look at the
flash costume so as you can see it's
Apple red it's not like the maroon of
grant gustin's costume it's much more
tech based it looks more like armor than
an actual suit that you would walk
around in his lightening is white it
looks a little more like traditional
lightning than the stylized version you
see on the TV show with like the
different colors of Speed Force
Lightning his layer here is hilarious I
love the set design it's a good metaphor
for his mind beat you know because he's
the flash he can process information
really fast he comes off like a complete
scatterbrained
even though internally he's actually
processing things like a normal person
would it's just that to other people
he seems like a complete scatterbrained
just because he can't slow down so this
is probably my favorite scene in the
trailer here it's you know it's very
Robert Downey jr. spider-man
war scene where Barry walks in and he
just sees Bruce sitting there like uh
hey what's up random dude what are you
doing in here he doesn't know that he's
Batman till Bruce throws the Batarang at
him
it goes into slow motion you see like
the little light bulb appear above his
head and he's like oh my god this dude
is Batman so it gives you good sense for
Barry Allen's personality in contrast
with Aquaman like Aquaman it's like you
want me to be on your team like
bodyslams Batman the flash on the other
side of that totally says yes before
Batman can even get through his sentence
like I'm putting a team two in then he
just like stops him I'm totally in I'm
down please be my friend
so just completely adorable Jeff John
said something really cool about the
flash - is that because he moved so fast
everyone else is standing still by
comparison he's very lonely he lives in
a world by himself like they haven't
really explained it in the comics of the
TV show very well because he like he
runs around with the communicator in his
ear so he does hear people at STAR Labs
talking to him but under normal
circumstances when the flash is moving
at SuperSpeed
sound waves don't travel to him so he
can't hear anything so it's almost like
he's traveling around in the silent
world with a bunch of mannequins just
standing still so he's very lonely and
it definitely does not help that he's a
metahuman and as we've seen in this
world so far metahumans aren't the most
popular people Lex Luthor has been
researching them so it looks like the
world is slowly getting ready to learn
about all them because the other big
thing here they tease the mother box so
you see like these Viking looking people
burying it in the ground this is
obviously at the end of the first
Darkseid war I mentioned this in a
couple other videos but they say in the
ancient history of the world that the
Atlanteans in Amazon in another ancient
one fought off Darkseid a long long time
ago three mother boxes were left behind
and that's what we saw in that deleted
scene from Batman V Superman
they've also confirmed that Steppenwolf
is gonna be the villain of this first
Justice League film so we're probably
not gonna see dark sight like we'll see
shades of him in the movie but he won't
actually be the big villain for a while
he's just too powerful for you to roll
him out right away so let me know what
you guys think about the footage in the
aesthetic of this like you definitely
get the sense that there's a lot more
humor in this film I think they found a
nicer balance between the real light
serious tone of the universe the
circumstances that they're in they're
very dire circumstances but they also
let Batman be funny like he's a very
funny person Batman has a great sense of
humor but it
is very different from say like Barry
Allen's sense of humor so expect to see
more of that the next time they post a
big trailer it's probably gonna be
awhile before they post it but they've
been shooting justice league so I would
expect like the next really big Justice
League trailer whenever they start to
market Wonder Woman in the spring so get
Justice League hype it's gonna be
awesome
they haven't really explained how
Superman is coming back I'm expecting
him to show up relatively late in the
Justice League film because the first
part of the film is Bruce putting the
team together then recognizing the
threat probably getting their asses
handed to them by Steppenwolf then you
know Superman probably shows up third
act that it's at least what I'm
expecting but just a reminder there's a
new round of the giveaway going on now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so because there's so many other videos
that are dropping today my next video
will probably be the flash season 3
trailer that we'll post in a couple
hours so there will be a lot of other
videos that will just post tomorrow so
anything I don't get to today I will
totally post tomorrow so no worries
while you guys wait for that video to
post you can click here for my Wonder
Woman trailer breakdown and you can
click here for all my other comic-con
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you